لاول مره منذ 70 عاما يودع البريطانيون
عامهم دون ملكتهم فقد ودعوها الودعا
الاخير قبل نهايه العام بنحو اربعه اشهر
في الثامنه من سبتمبر 2022 توفيت الملكه
اليزابيث الثانيه وفعلت العمليه المسمات
باسم هذا الجسر لندن بردج الاسم الحركي
لمراسم جنازه الملكه التي جرت تدرب عليها
لثلاثه عقود
[موسيقى]
بايام 10 القى عشرات الاف البريطانيين
نظره الوداع على نعش الملكه
ثم اقيمت لها جنازه رسميه وشعبيه مهيبه
حضرها العشرات من قاده العالم وكبار ساسته
الملكه العرش عام
1952 بعد وفاه ابيها جورج السادس كان
عمرها حينها قرابه السادسه والعشرين زوجه
لضابط البحريه البريطانيه واحد اقاربها
البعيدين الامير فيليب واما للاميرين
بوصول نجم بريطانيا
وانسلخت عن التاج البريطاني شيئا فشيئا
اخذت الشمس تغيبه عن الامبراطوريه
ليش 25 دوله على الاقل استقلت بعض الجزر
الصغيره في الكاريبي واغلب المستعمره
الافريقيه
الملكه بشعبيه كبيره بين مواطنيها
انا حزينه عليها للغايه
للجميع
لكن عهد الملكه الطويل
العهد
خلافات عميقه ثم النهايه الماساويه
ولا يخفى دور الملكه في تقويه الروابط بين
بلادها وباقي دول العالم وسجلها زاخر
بلقاءات عديده مع كبار القاده
رحلت اذن الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه وخلفها
ابنها تشارلز الثالث سيدا لقصر
يتواصلوا بذلك تربعه الي وينسر المستمر
منذ اكثر من 100 عاما على العرش البريطاني
اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن